who are you simon this is simon
come on do it again peter would be
thrilled to see you
so where are you from steven uh from
east putney
east partly east putney massive
okay simon yes off you go okay when i
was 10
my parents took me to a small farmer's
side
anyway we were going to a small farmer's
town we took the youth there
and so turned on this down
[Applause]
in my in my jandals and you know just
checking out the stuff mom and dad
this table and chairs that they thought
that's gonna be perfect in the dining
room
[Music]
sitting on the back dad decides seeing a
bit of formula
probably a bit quicker than he should
have me on my chair
bang pull down on the road like that
who's there hello sir hi there hi what's
your name ryan
ryan and where are you from ryan i'm
from new zealand oh lovely home of the
story new zealand
and are you traveling have you seen
living here for two years for two just
just two years
yeah yeah
what are you doing what are you doing
for two years i'm an electrician an
electrician
yeah it's a handy uh okay uh off screen
get his card how'd you go with the story
right
so i was at a new year festival um i'd
had a bit too much to drink during the
day in the campground
i was walking along to the festival and
i needed to get rid of a bit of what i'd
drunk um so
i saw a whole lot of portals i ran up to
them
ripped the door open uh projectile
spewed everywhere
then i looked down and i just spewed all
over a guy who was sort of relieving
himself on the loo
i was a bit freaked out first thing that
came to mind he looked angry he was
going to whack me
i gave him a bit of a whack myself slam
the door
i quite know that's
awful no i quite like that he vomited in
someone and then hit them
[Applause]
hello hello how you doing i'm very well
and who are you
my name is brittany brittany and uh
where are you from brittany i'm from new
zealand
new zealand we love a new zealand girl
we love
music long story short we love a new
zeal
uh and do you live here now brittany yes
i'm living in london working oh great
what are you doing britney i am working
as a nanny
lovely not paying any tax
using our services walking on
[Applause]
well i was out one night for a friend's
birthday um
we're having a few drinks where we ran
into a couple of very cute
irish brothers oh yes um so a few drinks
later one thing led to another and i
actually went home with one of the
brothers
um but i was rudely awoken in the middle
of the night and he was
standing in the corner peeing so i sort
of woke up went what are you doing what
are you doing
he got a fright and sort of think he was
half asleep went to the toilet
all was well woke up in the morning and
went okay this is where it gets awkward
do i tell him what do i do
um thought i'm never gonna see this guy
again so i went um do you remember
peeing in the corner last night and you
went no no no i didn't it was all
embarrassed
so when i went over and checked the
corner and there was nothing there it
was dry
i went oh i've dreamt at what you know
what actually happened
so anyway he was dropping me off home
thought i'd get dressed and went to put
on my shoes and realised he'd peed in my
shoes
but i didn't actually tell him i just
carried on home
and threw the shoes out when i got home
okay
i'm saying i think you should walk
that's quite a good one what do you
what's cough saying i like that story
she should walk but in her shoes
uh brittany you can walk i'm here well
done brittany
hello hi hi hi what's your name sir my
name's nick
nick lovely where are you from nick i'm
from new zealand but i live here
oh you live here next wednesday what do
you do here
i'm a paramedic a parent a proper job
and everything yeah
we're glad you're here yes
uh okay off you go with your story sir
uh so when i was a paramedic back in new
zealand
uh one sunday afternoon i went to a guy
that chopped
uh three fingers off from the lawnmower
oh and we packaged his hand up
we had to look for his fingers in the
bush and the hedge and everything like
that
and we rushed him to hospital because if
they get to hospital in time they can
reattach the fingers
and on the way to hospital i said you're
40 years old
how do you know not to put your hands at
the bottom of a lawnmower
and he said i was driving home one uh
this afternoon
and i saw that a guy had picked up the
lawnmower
turned her on his side and walked across
the front of his hedge
and he said it's a brilliant idea
so he did his lawns and then he did that
as he turned up to hospital
we walked into recess to see the surgeon
and we walked past another person
and he said hey that's the guy i saw
[Applause]
hello hello
these are the easy bits and what's your
name sir uh my name's bread
bread bread bread
i think i feel like a barista at
starbucks i'm just having bread on the
cob
okay brad sorry and where are you from
brad new zealand of course you are
they're always from new zealand i don't
know new zealand must be empty there's
no you must go to new zealand
the airport is deserted they're all
queuing for the red chair
okay brad uh uh do you live here if
you're just visiting uh i'm living in
london
okay what do you do here uh i'm working
in a marketing department for a
university in london oh that's quite a
proper job doesn't it yeah well done
brad
okay brian obviously uh so i was in
italy actually
uh in naples and uh was walking down the
street
and it was obviously in a lightning
storm and there was a
heck of a lot of rain coming down a very
very kind old lady offered me shelter
in her house and i went in she made me a
coffee and she offered me a change of
clothing
it was when i was in the room next door
trying to put my leg through the
trousers that i tripped over
i knocked a bookshelf and the urn on the
top of the bookshelf
came crashing down i was still wet from
the rain
and as the urn hit the ground the ash
went
all over me
to make matters a little bit worse as i
paul managed to pull the pants uh up
around my waist
and started to clean up the mess that i
had made i saw a photo
and it was the lady's husband well what
looked like her husband
uh and he was wearing the same pants
that i would
that was potentially the most
embarrassing and awkward that is a very
good story
excellent you can walk walk bread do you
want to be blunt no walk
are you gonna be blue oh you want to be
okay there you go bread
hey very good that was a good story
lots of detail it was extra the short
story in that
normally matthew they're not very no
hello
hello hi what's your name i'm andy andy
uh
are you from new zealand yes yes
embassy music you must have toured new
zealand i've never toured new zealand
though
you kidding me you're kidding me i would
love to i never went down
you've been everywhere i know everywhere
about new zealand let's hear a story
i'll pick over this right okay so i was
uh out for a run with my friend dunk
and uh we were running past the
and dunk really needed to go for a poo
so
we saw a woman can i just stop you
that's why you've never been to new
zealand
so we saw a toilet block and there was a
men's and a woman's and
we ran over to the men's and he was
busting he really needed to get this
thing out of him
and the men's was closed so at this
stage he didn't even care so he went
over to the women's
toilet and that was closed as well so
he's frantically looking around where
can i go where can i go so he ran
over to this this bush and crouched down
behind this bush and he went and about
30 seconds later
i saw this a big german shepherd came
bounding over and dunk pulled his pants
up
jogged off and then this uh and then
about 20 seconds later
the owner of the german shepherd came
over and she was like
oh roy
[Applause]
hello hello hello hello okay now
focus everyone focus okay sorry i'm
trying to focus the couch
yeah uh what's your name sir uh i'm sam
from new zealand
oh new zealand we like new zealand
he just tapped himself
[Applause]
okay sam so i know really i would really
gather yourself all right
okay uh just go with your story go with
your story okay um so my story actually
involves one of your guests graham
um uh helena
so yeah my mum's a nurse and um she used
to live in london
she told me not to tell the story and
she's probably going to kill me now
do you want to vote sorry
hello
[Applause]
okay here you go here you go sam so your
mother told you not to tell the story
helen is in it go okay she's in it um
mum was a nurse and
she actually used to look after her
father for a while when they lived above
the flat
and anyway um mum would have a key and
should go up every now and again i think
one time she was actually in the
bathroom
and she heard someone singing around
singing around and so she opened the
door
and um helena's dancing out naked
dancing with some sort of song
and yeah that's where my mum first kind
of they kind of met and you know that's
it
[Applause]
it's easier
you